[Musique]
certicom des émeraudes dans l'océan
indien l'archipel des seychelles est un
paradis terrestre pour l'homme mais
perdu au delà des limites
isolé dans un vide immense il existe un
atoll que l'homme a oublié c'est un des
endroits les moins accessibles et les
plus dangereux du monde
c'est aussi un extraordinaire musée
vivant c'est lille légendaire d'aldabra
[Musique]
à
pendant des siècles victoria la capitale
des seychelles a été un carrefour pour
les navigateurs
c'est ici que les marchands indien
persan et arabes comme les corsaires et
boucaniers français anglais chercher
refuge pour réparer leur bateau
endommagé par les cyclones de la région
aujourd'hui le sloop aquarius se prépare
pour un voyage qui peut s'avérer
périlleux
il faut ravitailler aldabra l'île
interdite
l'autorisation du gouvernement des
seychelles pour se rendre à l' dabra est
rarement accordé le scientifique
britannique john colis s'est débrouillé
pour faire la traversée
mais tout comme l'équipage il fait
l'objet d'un contrôle minutieux
il faut dissuader ceux qui sont
téméraires ou inexpérimenté trop de
bateaux sont partis à leur perte dont
les eaux d'aldabra ce voyage a été
autorisée afin d'apporter de l'eau de la
nourriture et du courrier à l'équipe qui
veille sur l'île et qui vit dans des
conditions aussi austère que sur une
station lunaire
l'aquarius se dirige au coeur d'une zone
où généralement les cyclones font ravage
mais aujourd'hui les conditions sont
parfaites le vent souffle et la mer est
calme
le cap est mis sur le sud ouest pour une
des plus spectaculaires croisière au
monde
cinq jours durant l'aquarius suit sa
route le long de l'archipel des
seychelles se frayant un chemin entre
les récifs passant tout près deal comme
celle de robinson crusoé bientôt le
capitaine va virer vers le large la
navigation doit être précise car il
serait facile de dépasser aldabra et de
se retrouver quelques jours après sur la
côte africaine
philippe maroci capitaine de l'aquarius
son second et étienne le cuisinier
doivent profiter du voyage pour faire
des stocks de nourriture pour le camp
d'aldabra le choc des seychelles regorge
de multiples variétés de poissons des
capitaines rouge des vieilles des
bourgeois et bien d'autres ici vous
n'avez qu'à laisser traîner une ligne
pour recueillir les richesses de l'océan
cette fois ci les qui passe au dessus
d'un banc de barracuda
mais ici quasiment tout est comestible
c'est pas si les rivaux
à auch
pensons seulement 1 dans les veaux
un peu de blanc
[Applaudissements]
john colis le biologiste consacre sa vie
à la protection de la nature sauvage
d'aldabra il projette un contrôle des
espèces menacées d'extinction
il n'aura que trois jours aldabra et
doit bien se préparer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
trois journées en mer depuis victoria et
l'aquarius atteint le groupe d'alphonse
recouverte de plantation de noix de coco
ou creuser par l'extraction du guano ce
sont les dernières île peuplée que l'on
rencontre philippe doit contourner à
labyrinthes de recife s'engageant dans
des chenaux étroits avec des noms tels
que le passage de la mort là qui évite
de justesse le corail tranchant en ce
lieu temps réputé pour ses contre
courant et bancs de sable mouvant
il faut beaucoup de prudence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on donne trop longtemps
au nom
enfin au large l'aquarius peut naviguer
sans entraves vers aldabra mais il reste
encore deux jours de soleil agressif
aveuglant où le mercure va grimper au
dessus de 40 degrés l'arrivée de
frégates et de fou à la recherche de
nourriture signale que lille d'aldabra
leurs sanctuaires n'est pas loin nous
pénétrons un monde étrange qui est le
royaume
[Applaudissements]
la raison pour laquelle ils se trouvent
ici c'est que l'eau qui sort de la passe
ou arrow est très nutritive et les fous
se nourrissent de cette eau venant du
lago et voilà tout ces frégates qui
tourne autour attendant le moment où les
fouilles reprendront leurs vols pour les
attaquer et rattraper les poissons
qu'ils auront lâché
les bons de dauphin viennent aussi se
nourrir dans ses eaux
ils sont intrigués par cette intrusion
de l'homme si rare dans ces lieux et
soudain apparaît ce mystérieux reflets
verts dans le ciel qui annonce lille
d'aldabra les navigateurs arabes avaient
déjà noté ce phénomène très particulier
en 915 il surnommèrent l'atoll al khadra
la verte
philippe doit maintenant affronter ça
plus rude épreuve de marins la plupart
du temps la météo et les marées
interdisent l'accès aldabra l'homme est
tenue à distance dans la baie même si
les conditions aujourd'hui sont
favorables les coraux à céret écorche la
coque les courants sont imprévisibles et
les vents capricieux dans des conditions
autre qu une mer calme
il est impossible de voir cet atoll sans
relief il n'émerge que de quelques
mètres au-dessus de l'eau et
d'innombrables bateaux l'ont déjà heurté
mais pour john colis ces dangers ne
peuvent l'emporter sur l'excitation de
son retour aldabra l'extraordinaire j'ai
passé presque deux années aldabra la
dernière fois c'était il y a deux ans je
reviens ici pour une troisième fois pour
un court séjour
si vous travaillez à aldabra pendant
deux ans et vous la quittez vous
laisserai toujours un peu de votre coeur
aldabra et c'est bon d'être de retour
et
[Applaudissements]
l'arrivée sur l'île évoque une sorte
d'avant postes du bout du monde
il n'y a ni eau ni terre pour l'homme la
simple survie est un exploit les stocks
de nourriture fraîche ainsi que les
nouvelles des familles sont les
bienvenues
la dernière venue d'un bateau remonte à
plus de trois mois
toni moral et l'administrateur de lille
sa mission est l'étude de l'atoll et la
préservation de l'un des plus grands
lagons du monde
de plus de 120 km de pur tour former des
rebords d'un volcan sous marin couronné
de corail vivant
la base est tout petit c'est uniquement
en réduisant au minimum l'impact de
l'homme ici que l'écosystème demeure
inaltérée john lit les lettres des
femmes et des enfants de l'équipe
il se renseigne sur les tortues vertes
temps menacé sa principale préoccupation
plus tard il ira voir lui-même les lieux
de ponte
il y à un rythme de vie si qui est
habile équilibre entre l'étude et la
protection de la nature et les routines
de survie l'équipe fait son pain tous
les deux jours la consommation de crabes
d'écrevisses et même de noix de coco est
interdite
malgré leur abondance il n'y a pas de
légumes les insulaires mange du pain du
riz et du poisson le matin du poisson du
riz et du par le soir les visiteurs ont
apporté de la nourriture car toute pêche
n'est possible qu'à une heure de voile
d'aldabra l' équilibre naturel des
espèces en dépend les poissons pêchés au
large sont salée séchée au soleil puis
stockée pour travailler ici il faut
s'engager à fond et accepter les
conditions de vie rudimentaire
normalement on a un contrat d ingénieurs
un centre de recherche météorologique
étudie les origines des grands cyclones
et fournit des statistiques sur
l'évolution des climats et l'intensité
solaire le niveau de la mer est
constamment surveillé pour mesurer le
réchauffement de la planète mais c'est
le manque d'eau de pluie qui pose ici le
plus de problèmes par le passé l'homme a
essayé de dominer exploiter aldabra mais
il a échoué
les rêves de plantation de noix de coco
et demande comme ceux du commerce du
bois sont morts en même temps que les
hommes qui ont osé défier les éléments
ici ils sont tombés victimes de la soif
ou de la foudre et repose à côté des
victimes de naufrages et d' attaques de
pirates
il est presque impossible de se déplacer
à pied au delà des limites du camp les
rochers pourrait mettre en lambeaux les
bottes les plus solides
le sol dissimulent des gouffres qui
plonge directement dans la mer
l'atoll est un énorme piège pour l'homme
ce n'est qu'en bateau que la vie
d'aldabra peut être étudié la profondeur
du lagon varie entre 50 cm et 2 mètres
50 selon la marée et la saison
l'incursion dans ce monde secret sauvage
exige une préparation très précises
l'érosion du corail sous la forme des
tranches champignons renforce la
sensation d'être sur une autre planète
à deux heures du camp c'est un royaume
d'oiseaux très rares à faire rêver la
plupart des ornithologues
cette atonie de découvrir leur lieu de
prédilection pour y emmener les
scientifiques il y à un million de
frégates et de fou mais également des
râles des ibis sacrés des aigrettes des
hérons cendrés les mangroves
impénétrable et les forteresses de
corail défendent leur environnement
contre les intrus c'est ainsi que ce
musée vivant peut rester intacte
[Musique]
tony c'est quand il faut avoir peur ou
non il peut même jouer avec un petit
requin dans le lagon pour démontrer
qu'un requin rassasié n'attaque pas
l'homme
john va désormais passer deux jours à
contrôler la population d'une espèce qui
a survécu depuis la préhistoire mais
menacées d'extinction depuis le siècle
dernier suite à une chasse acharnée
voilà l'habitant le plus célèbre
d'aldabra la tortue géante d'aldabra on
est ici à grande terre où ces reptiles
préhistoriques survivants très grand
nombre depuis plus de 118 mille ans on
estime à plus de cent cinquante mille le
nombre de tortues qui vivent en liberté
à travers aldabra c'est vraiment un
spectacle étonnant
celle ci est plutôt petite elle a à peu
près 25 ans on détermine son agent
content avec attention les anneaux de
croissance sur une écaille
on commence au milieu et on compte vers
l'extérieur pour avoir l'âge
approximatif d'une tortue les plus
grandes atteignent presque 200 kg celle
ci pèse environ 25 kg elle est assez
petit
si on la met sur son dos on voit par sa
carapace aplati que c'est une femelle
les mâles eux ont une carapace très con
case qui facilite l'accouplement la
queue de la femelle est aussi beaucoup
plus petite que celle du mal
il ya eu une époque où ces tortues
géantes d'aldabra habitait toutes les
îles des seychelles
mais à la fin du xviiie siècle
leur nombre a diminué radicalement en
raison des marins européens venus du
portugal en route pour lorient ou le
moyen-orient qui faisaient escale aux
seychelles pour réparer leur bateau et
se réapprovisionner en eau et en vivres
en effet si elles ont été capturées
c'est parce qu'elles peuvent rester
plusieurs semaines sans boire ni manger
les marins les regrouper par centaines
pour les stocker sur les bateaux
retournés sur leur dos sur leur dos
comme ça les rendant complètement
immobile les marins remplissait ainsi la
soutes des bateaux de tortues vivantes
pour assurer des provisions de
nourriture pour de longues semaines en
mer
ces tortues pourrait bien être
centenaire certaines ont plus de 150 ans
et était peut-être là quand darwin
lui-même lutter pour arrêter leur
massacre en 1835 elle ne survivait k2
endroit sur terre où galapagos et sur
aldabra les scientifiques de plusieurs
pays ont soutenue darwin dans cette
première campagne mondiale pour la
sauvegarde d'une espèce la seule menace
aujourd'hui pour la communauté des
tortues géantes vient des chèvres
sauvages
abandonné par d'anciens habitants et qui
mange la végétation du sol dont les
tortues ont besoin pour se nourrir
le temps change en un instant dans ce
coin de l'océan indien
tout le monde retourne au camp un
cyclone est improbable mais personne ne
veut se retrouver sans abri
même dans un orage tropical de moindre
importance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
philippe doit faire un rapport sur la
situation écologique du monde sous-marin
d'aldabra et fournir des images aux
biologistes marins cousteau est venu
dans ces eaux sur son bateau laboratoire
la calypso pour le tournage du monde du
silence
un des plus beau film jamais tourné sous
la mer
la température de l'océan reste à 30
degrés l'eau est riche en substances
nutritives la chaîne alimentaire est
hautement développées et cet écosystème
marin coexistent en parfaite harmonie
avec l'écosystème terrestre
[Musique]
[Rires]
soudain une tortue verte passe à toute
allure
sa silhouette effilée fait d'elle une
excellente nageuse la survie de cette
espèce est encore très précaire et sahar
présence ici sera signalé à junk olic
qui va rechercher des femelles en pondre
sur les plages d'aldabra mais il faudra
attendre encore une heure ou deux
jusqu'à la nuit
et c'est alors que le reptile le plus
précieux du monde arrivera sur la plage
[Musique]
la recherche des tortues vertes peut
alors commencer
mais c'est une autre créature nocturne
d'aldabra qui captent d'abord
l'attention des biologistes une espèce
de plus qui a pratiquement disparu de
l'océan indien
si vous vous promenez la nuit sur
aldabra la seule chose à laquelle vous
devez faire attention c'est le coconut
crabe géant ou le cipayes comme on
l'appelle ici
ce crabe doc turne peuple aldabra par
milliers celui que vous voyez la
recherche sa nourriture principale la
noix de coco mais ce crabe se nourrit de
tout de la vie ronde morte du poisson il
mange tout ce qui traîne aldabra mais
son aliment principale et la noix de
coco qu'il décortique avec cette
terrible pas je vais vous faire une
démonstration
vous voyez les énormes pince devant ces
choses sont très puissantes et si vous
vous y faites passez le doigt
ça va faire très mal
ces crabes d'aldabra sont plutôt
terriens ils tendent leurs oeufs dans la
mer mais c'est leur seul rapport avec
elle ensuite il nage en attendant
l'éclosion des larves pour revenir sur
la terre où il passe le reste de leur
vie
par ailleurs il existe deux coloration
différente
celui ci est rouge on en trouve d'autres
comme celui là qui sont bleus mais à
part leurs couleurs ils sont exactement
pareil
pour la tortue verte de mer aldabra a
toujours été une mecque depuis les temps
les plus lointains ces tortues jaune est
en très grand nombre sur les plages
d'aldabra pour pondre leurs oeufs
mais aujourd'hui il n'y a plus que deux
mille de ces reptiles qui reviennent
chaque année pour pondre sur aldabra à
cause des massacres perpétrés par les
humains dans le passé pendant la saison
des amours ensemble le mâle et la
femelle à rives du canal du mozambique
où ils se nourrissent pour s'accoupler
ici aldabra la femelle vient sur la
plage mais le mal reste au large ils ne
participent pas à la ponte ni à la
protection de ces jeunes tortues
nageront jusqu'à 1600 km de ses plages
mais les femelles reviendront exactement
au même endroit pour pondre leurs oeufs
dans huit ans un processus de navigation
que les scientifiques cherchent encore à
comprendre
la mère fait tout pour protéger ses
oeufs mais seulement cinq sur son
survivront
la moyen de ponte ici est de 125 à 130
quand la tortue a terminé elle commence
à recouvrir de sable les oeufs avec
grand soin elle y prête tant d'attention
c'est incroyable elle veille à ne pas
toucher les oeufs du tout avec ses
nageoires
si aussi peu de tortues vertes survivent
aujourd'hui il faut mettre en cause
l'avarice et la cruauté des hommes
la chaire de tortue et la soupe de
tortue ont été si apprécié et ont subi
une telle inflation que les méthodes
d'abattage sont devenus brutales et
systématiques en effet jusqu'à récemment
plusieurs gouvernements ont montré un
mépris total envers la vie sauvage
d'aldabra en 1962 l'angleterre et
l'amérique avait planifié de raser la
surface de l'atoll avec tout ce qui vit
pour construire une base aérienne
stratégique une mobilisation désespérée
de dernière heure des scientifiques du
monde entier a pu sauver des milliers
d'espèces de l'extermination aujourd'hui
aldabra appartient à l'humanité entière
grâce à une donation du peuple
seychellois l'unesco met cependant
certains parlent d'un tourisme restreint
orienté vers la science ce qui protège
aldabra s'inquiète déjà mais des
contrôles rigoureux ont été promis john
colis et les autres biologiste qui
débarque aldabra veulent que ce musée
vivant devienne autre chose qu'un lieu
de dernier espoir de survie
ils le voient comme un sanctuaire où les
espèces pourrait se rétablir et
prospérer comme l'a fait la tortue
géante leur tâche va exiger des
décennies de travail
en attendant il souhaite qu aldabra
demeure lille que l'homme le prédateur a
oublié
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]